- Do you sing all the time?
- I can't help it,
but I do want to say something to you.
I brought you a gift.
Because, there is only a few people
that I can re-gift things to.
And the reason is, is
because we share something,
we share actually many things in common.
- We do.
- But I would like for you
to go ahead and open this up.
Now, I got two.
So, I'm being honest with
you, I'm re-gifting this.
- Are these best friend necklaces?
Are we best friends?
- Are we getting married?
(laughter)
- I'm so in.
- I think that's gonna happen.
But anyway, go ahead, and you'll see
why I'm gonna remember--
- Oh my gosh.
- Okay, so we have the same initials.
- I know, I was literally, when
I sent the video memo today
I was like,
"From KC to KC."
I thought it was so clever.
It's not that funny.
- I got three of these, three!
- Oh, so you don't need 'em all.
I love it!
(audience applause)
Wait, is this for jewelry?
Or like, what is this?
- What you do is you put 'em
on your shoe and just so you know,
Katie Couric got the other one.
- Oh, there we go, the other KC.
I actually know a lot of
people with our initials.
It's weird.
(animal noise)
What in the world?
It sounded like a gremlin got out.
- It's the kookaburra!
- It's the kookaburra.
I can't say it with a cool accent.
- I actually practiced doing him.
- Okay wait, can you harmonize with that?
If we played it, could you
harmonize with the kookaburra?
Okay, Robert, Bindi--
- Yeah.
- Can you bring the bird out?
I'm gonna harmonize with Kristin.
Come on.
We're gonna harmonize, we're gonna do it.
We can do it.
- This is so exciting.
- Hi, y'all.
- Good to see you.
- Look, it's my size.
(laughter)
- All right, okay he may
not make a sound now,
Moe won't but hey, can we play it?
We're gonna try--
this is the sound.
- This is it, okay.
(kookaburra call)
(Kristin mimicking kookaburra call)
- That was amazing.
I love you.
- He doesn't know what to do.
This is amazing.
- This is like most of my boyfriends,
they're scared of me!
- No literally, you are so great.
- I think he likes you, definitely.
That was very good.
- I thought I got that (mimics kookaburra)
but not that (mimics kookaburra).
- You are truly one of
those people that just
lights up the room, like
every room you walk in,
and I feel like we're
similar in the sense that
we're both kind of like
bubbly all the time,
but are you always like that?
- No.
No, I think it's--
and I think it's important to say this.
People think, there's
a conception about me,
and probably you too
that it's rainbows, and unicorns,
and glitter all the time.
But I'm human and I've struggled with
sadness and even--
- I've suffered from depression.
- Depression.
And people are like,
"Really?
"That can't be real,"
but I do
and I have tools that help me.
First of all, I have counseling.
I have a great mom that I talk to
and I have a great group
of core girlfriends
that really listen.
And I think that's--
and I have faith and for whatever faith is
for everybody else.
Mine's God so that helps.
What else is confusing, it
can happen from sometimes
left field and it can be
a small thing that kinda
makes me go,
"I'm sad,"
and you pull yourself out of it.
You put your big girl panties up.
Or you take the time, and
be sad, and move through it.
- I think you have to do that.
I think that you do, I'm clapping.
I also wanted to talk to you though,
because I know you're dating.
- Yes.
- You're dating so lie,
are you getting married
and do you wanna tell us now?
I'm just kidding.
- Girl talk.
You know what?
Not to get weird, but I think that also
it's important to say this, especially to
our younger fans and younger
generations of women.
I come from the Bible Belt in Oklahoma,
very proudly so, but with that means
that you're supposed to get married,
have two point five kids,
and live in the picket...
You know, white picket fence house.
And I didn't choose that for my life,
I had other goals
and at first, it was always a shame, like,
I shouldn't tell people
that maybe I'm not sure
about having children or even maybe
getting married, and I've
had great men in my life.
I've got a great one right now.
Marriage might be the deal, it might,
but it's never what's been my...
It hasn't been what's
defined me or driven me.
And for a long time, I
was shameful about it.
- Yeah, especially from where we're from.
- Because of where we're from.
And also,
thank you.
- Did people always think you were gay?
People thought I was gay forever.
- I've had some boyfriends to make me
wish I was gay, but no.
(Kelly laughs)
- Me too!
Me too.
- No, I'm not.
And as far as, like people will go,
"You're not gonna have a child?"
And it's almost like, oh selfish.
But I take care of a lot of kids.
I have many cousins, I have
Godchildren I take care of,
and this is also important to say,
as an adopted child, if I ever wanna--
if I had that so desire one
day and I wake up and I say,
"Maybe I missed the boat
or maybe I wanna do that,"
there's been so many
great examples of women
who've done that and I
would just adopt a child.
There's many out there.
- The thing about that two
is one, that you're picked.
Like my mom just got stuck with me.
(Kristin laughs)
Like, you were picked.
Like they got
to pick you.
- They do say you're chosen.
- Yeah, that's like really cool.
- It's a special feeling
and I've always known
about my adoption.
And you know, my family,
they're all chemical engineers,
and real tall, and you
know, they don't sing
and thy should never sing, actually ever.
But I don't do math.
But we learn from each other, you know?
- That's awesome.
That's so great.
All right, well tell
us about your new album
because I want it?
- Well it's called "For The Girls."
I made a record for the
girls, by the girls,
all the women that have inspired me.
You know, we're talking
Lesley Gore, Judy Garland,
Barbara Streisand, we're
talking Eva Cassidy.
- Love.
- We're talking a lot of the greats.
And I did it my way but I paid--
I tipped my hats to the greats.
'Cause "I'm a Woman,"
I asked Jennifer Hudson
and Reba to sing it with me.
And then I did "I Will
Always Love You" with Dolly,
which I can't believe--
- Gosh, that is insane.
- My extensions fell out of my head
when she said yes.
- She's the loveliest human ever.
That's the best compliment ever.
- Has anyone ever met anyone
that doesn't like Dolly Parton?
- She's the nicest human in the world.
- The nicest!
(audience applause)
- And you also,
this is what I find interesting,
you have a duet with
Ariana but you've known her
since she was little, right?
- Since she was seven
years old, Ariana Grande.
She came--
there we are, we did
"Hairspray Live" together.
I love that child.
She came back to see "Wicked,"
her grandma brought her
and she said,
"My granddaughter wants to sing,"
and I said,
"Oh well that's sweet," you know,
"good luck."
(laughter)
And then she--
- Worldwide superstar.
- Yeah, so I'm like,
"Okay, we'll see."
And then she kinda sang
something and I was like,
oh, I checked myself
because she was really good.
And I said,
"Here's a little wand,"
because I created the
role of Glenda and I said,
"Keep that with you and
have that with you,"
and she kept it all these
years, we've stayed close,
and I wanted to bring...
I wanted to bring her in the record
and we did "You Don't Own
Me," Lesley Gore's tune.
And it's, I'm so proud of her.
I love her.
- Oh my God, that's so cool.
That's so cool.
- Thank you.
- It's super, super great.
So when are you taking
the album to Broadway?
When can people see it?
It's in November, right?
- Yeah, the first two weekends in November
I'll be playing on Broadway
with "For The Girls"
and have very special guests come.
And it's at the Nederlander
Theater and you can
get tickets now and please come see it.
- Oh my God, it's gonna be great.
Here's the funny thing though.
We both have like, Broadway in common
'cause we both grew--
well, you have like actual Broadway.
And then I just grew
up in musical theater.
It's very different.
But my point is is I remember
my very first musical
when I was a little kid, I was like,
"Oh, we're--
"Okay, so we're just
gonna break out in song,
"like we were just talking
and then we're just gonna
"break out in song, and
then we're gonna go back--"
- Yeah, we call that a Monday on Broadway.
- I know, but it's so awkward.
It's a beautiful thing but I was like,
how awkward is that that you just like
go all the sudden in song--
♪ How can it be ♪
♪ I feel like I have known her forever ♪
♪ Could she be my less talented ♪
♪ And long lost sister ♪
- Oh my gosh, so like
the crazy thing, though,
about this is now you're
in a movie with Scott Wolf
and you're doing the Hallmark thing?
- Yes.
- I love Hallmark Christmas movies.
- Oh my God, it's a good movie,
Scott Wolf's in it and
his dreamy, blue eyes.
And I wrote the title song for it.
You'll love it.
- [Kelly] What's the title song called?
- "A Christmas Story," Hallmark, watch it.
- Oh my God, that's so great.
♪ It all makes sense ♪
♪ I'll never be alone now ♪
♪ It all ♪
♪ Makes sense ♪
♪ She'll always be right here ♪
(audience cheering)
- Oh my gosh, so tell me about
the tabernacle choir thing,
that's crazy.
So you sing with them.
- The tabernacle choir's
a rite of passage--
you need to do it, girl.
- You're cooler than me,
let's just get this over with.
- That's gonna happen.
I'll help it.
- So how did you get involved with that?
- They asked me to do it so I
finally took the opportunity
and I got to do it.
And it comes on at Christmas.
- Aw!
♪ I finally found her ♪
♪ Yes you found me ♪
♪ And we'll always be ♪
- I love having you here.
- I love you.